FIRST WHILE PARKS AND WILDLIFE-
MEETING. WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE MEETING WILL LAST FOR
A ROLL CALL. THIS IS JUST
EDUARDO GARCIA WAS IT. MAKING
DAILY. BIGELOW CHOI. CHOOSE
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA.
GLORIA KALRA LEVINE. MATHIS
BROTHERS BLANCA RUBIO SALAS
WOULD. NINE WE HAVE A ONE BILL
AUTHORS HERE AB FIVE FIVE NINE
WHEN WE CONCLUDE- THE BRIDGE IN
THAT MATTER OF A FEW REMARKS
AND INTRODUCE OUR VICE CHAIR TO
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL. SO OF
SUMMER PLEASE COME FOR. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB FIVE FIVE NINE IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY TO
DEVELOP AND MANAGE THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER PARKWAY. THE
VISION OF THE CONSERVANCY WAS
TO CREATE A TWENTY TWO MILE
NATURAL AND RECREATIONAL AREA
IN THE FLOOD PLAIN EXTENDING
FROM PRYING DAM TO HIGHWAY
NINETY NINE. FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY SIX YEARS THIS
CONSERVANCY IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES OF
FRESH OWN MADERA AND MANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING STATE.
WORKED HARD BOOK. ENTER INTO
PARTNERSHIPS TO MAKE THIS
PARKWAY A REALITY. HOWEVER MUCH
WORK STILL REMAINS IN ORDER TO
FULLY OPERATE AND MANAGE THE
PARKWAY THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
IS A SEVERELY UNDERSERVED AND
CONTINUES TO FALL FAR BEHIND
IN. THE RATE OF PARKS PER
CAPITA AS A POSITION I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF SPENDING TIME
OUTDOORS DIABETES HYPERTENSION
OBESITY THESE COULD ALL BE
ALLEVIATED SIMPLY BY SPENDING
MORE TIME OUTDOORS IF ONLY WE
COULD PROVIDE THE SAFE AND
AVAILABLE RECREATIONAL AREA FOR
ALL TO ENJOY. AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
ACCOMPLISH. AB FIVE FIVE NINE
NAMED FOR THE AREA CODE IN
WHICH I REPRESENT WOULD ALLOW
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY THE ABILITY TO
ENTER INTO A MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENT WITH THE STATE PARKS
AND WOULD PROVIDE FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE OF
THE TRAILS AND SPACES. THAT THE
PARK HAS ACQUIRED. AB FIVE FIVE
NINE WILL HELP PROVIDE HEALTHY
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO A
PART OF THE STATE THAT IS
SEVERELY LACKING GREEN SPACE.
TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE CLOSEST
STATE PARK I HAVE IS EIGHTY SIX
MILES AWAY. I HAVE A
RECREATIONAL AREA AND A
HISTORIC SITE CLOSE TO US BUT I
HAVE NO STATE PARK FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM. HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
SHARON WEAVER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER PARKWAY TRUST. GOOD
MORNING MR SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBER SO- AGAIN MY NAME IS
SHARON WEAVER AT THEIR RIVER
PARKWAY TRUST WHICH IS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT I REPRESENT
IS A FIVE OH ONE C. THREE NON
PROFIT WE WERE FORMED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT FEW YEARS
BEFORE THE STATE CONSERVANCY.
AND WE ARE ONE OF THOSE KEY
PARTNERS AND CREATING AND
PROVIDING MANAGEMENT EXPERTISE
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER PARK.
WE ART TO HELP MANAGE THE PART
APPROPRIATELY SO IT IS A HUGE
ASSET TO OUR REGION. AND
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY CAN
BENEFIT FROM. FROM THE HEALTH
BENEFITS- INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH BENEFITS FROM WALKING
AND RUNNING AND SPENDING TIME
OUTDOORS TO ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. THAT WE
PROVIDE AT NUMEROUS SITES ALONG
THE RIVER AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE WAY THE STATE
HAS INVESTED IN AND PROTECTING
LAND ALONG THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER PARKWAY. BUT WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANDY LESS BILL THAT THE
STATE WILL NOW HELP WITH THE
MANAGEMENT AND OPERATIONS OF
THE PARKWAY IN THE FUTURE BY
WORKING THROUGH THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM. SO I THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS BILL TODAY AND
I HOPE YOU WILL MOVE FORWARD.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. USER MOTION THE BILL
DOES HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
PASS. A MOTION BY MISS GARCIA
SEC MY DOCTOR WOULD. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. PLEASE. I THANK
YOU AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE OB MISTER ON THE LINE I
HAVE GIVEN DISTRICTS WITH A LOT
OF THE SAME PROBLEMS ACTUALLY-
INCLUDING- POR PART COMMUNITIES
AND OFTENTIMES OUR CITIES OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN'T AFFORD
TO ACQUIRE THE LAND AND MAYBE
EVEN DO THE MAINTENANCE ON THE
ROAD AND SO THE STATE STEPPING
INTO BE PARTNERS I THINK IT'S A
MODEL THAT WE NEED TO BE
PURSUING- ALONG THE WAY SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THAT AND MAYBE
A MODEL WITH A LOOK AT ACROSS
THE STATE BY THE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. YOU GIVE ME A
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OKAY
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND SAID
THIS HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SELECT CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK US FOR ROCCA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GARCIA AYE DALY
AYE DALY AYE. BIGELOW BIGELOW
NOT VOTING. CHOI CHOI I. TO
FRIEDMAN I FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA. STINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
KALRA LEVINE MATHIS- MATHIS I
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOULD WOULD
I. SEVEN OR IT WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON AS I MENTIONED IN THE
OPENING REMARKS I WANT TO
WELCOME OUR VICE CHAIR THAT
MISS MAKING DOLLY FROM FIRST
DISTRICT HE WILL BE FILLING IN-
WHEN WE'RE NOT HERE EITHER ON
TIME WORK- I'M NOT HERE TO
FACILITATE THE MEETING. AS YOU
ALL KNOW THIS IS THE SECOND.
YEAR OF OUR TWO YEARS. EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO ALSO WELCOME MAY.
OUR SIDE FELLOW MAY THE BOY OF
IT. I THINK I SAID THAT RIGHT
MY AUNT THAT WELCOME WE'RE
EXCITED TO HAVE YOU AS WELL AS-
THERE'S A GOOD TRACK RECORD OF
SCIENCE FELLOWS- IN THIS
COMMITTEE- ULTIMATELY HAVING A
GREATER. SAY IN INPUT- IN- THE
WORK THAT WE DO HAVE CAPITAL SO
WELCOME AND GOOD LUCK THIS YEAR
AT THE SAME TIME- I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT OUR CONSULTANTS IN
THE COMMITTEE WILL BE REACHING
OUT TO YOUR OFFICE- TO GET SOME
INPUT SOME FEEDBACK ON THE
TYPES OF ISSUES THAT YOU'D LIKE
US TO. TAKE A LOOK AT AS IT
RELATES TO AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS. AND YOU HAVE A SET OF
ISSUES THAT I THINK WILL. COME
UP. BE A BILLS AND OTHER
DISCUSS. PROBABLY WILL COME
FROM THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
CLIMATE RESILIENCY YOU KNOW THE
ISSUE OF ACCESS AND SPACES
URBAN PATROL. SYSTEMS AND
THINGS OF THAT SORT I THINK
WILL BE SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE WILL. BE LOOKING AT THIS
pLOOK FORWARD TO GETTING YOUR
FEEDBACK AND AGAIN- WELCOME
BACK AND- LET'S GET TO WORK SO.
THAT THANK YOU. WE'LL WE'LL
OPEN IT UP FOR ADDITIONS TO THE
ABOUT. AB FIVE FIVE NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GLORIA AREA I KALRA KALRA I
LEVINE LEVINE I. RUBIO. BLANCA
RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE. OKAY
WILL BE LEAVE IT OPEN JUST FOR
A FEW MORE MINUTES WE HAVE A
COUPLE OTHER MEMBERS COME IN.
BUT. THE. OKAY. OKAY WITH. THAT
WHETHER. SHE WAS ONE OF THE
TOUGHESTEXCERPTED FROM THE
.
OPEN UP THE ROLE. ISSUE AB FIVE
FIVE NINE TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TWO TWO I. YEAH.
IT WILL STAY OPEN FOR ANOTHER
FIVE MINUTES
. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP THE ROLE FOR MEMBER TO
ADD ON. AB FIVE NINETY PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SALAS SALAS AYE.
THIRTEEN OKAY THIRTEEN TWO ZERO
THE- MATTER WILL NOW MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS AND AT
THIS TIME WE WILL ADJOURN OUR
MEETING THANK YOU